so there's a direct correlation between
tastes and sight you see something that
looks delicious your mouth begins to
water you see something sour you pucker
but what about sound as it turns out
sound has a direct effect on how your
food tastes I'm hungry this concept is
being studied by Professor Charles
Spence I'm an experimental psychologist
and a gastro physicist the research is
in two parts part one we've found that
on the one hand people match music and
instruments and pictures of sounds to
different tastes and flavors and food
and drink so listening to a musical
scale you might say from this twizzler
tastes like an a note and these pretzels
taste like a G note and part two
we then play matching music that
corresponds to what you're tasting you
can use that to bring out and actually
change people's experience of sweetness
of flavor in the food and drinks that
they are consuming just like you can
pair wine with cheese Spence says that
you can pair music with wine
Tchaikovsky's string quartets low pitch
sounds kind of rumbling Vitamix better
to sort of a heavy red wine to bring out
business whereas Mozart's flute concerto
it's a much better match for certain
white wines showing that we can bring
out the sweetness he actually calls it
sonic seasoning and while music has now
been proven to accentuate flavor
it can also dull it loud background
noises actually dull are salty and sweet
taste receptors think about that next
time you served peanuts and pretzels on
an airplane
sort of the sweet taste do tend to be
suppressed by that background noise the
one flavor scent however that's not
impacted umami this is savory think
tomatoes beef carrots soy when you get
on the airplane it's amazing how many
people order tomato juice and Bloody
Marys the umami taste is one that is not
suppressed by loud noise like the sound
of the engines rumbling it's an
interesting concept and in the very
least the next time you go out to eat I
guarantee you'll pay just a little more
attention to the music that's playing in
the background